President Obama is going to speak at an
event here in New York a Wall Street
investment bank for $400,000 fee you
were critical of Hillary Clinton for
taking money like that what do you say
about President Obama making an even
larger fee look President Obama's a
friend of mine I think he as president
represented our country with integrity
and intelligence but I think at a time
when people are so frustrated with the
power of Wall Street and the big-money
interests I think it is unfortunate that
President Obama is is doing this you
know right now you have president
Trump's key economic adviser as you know
is Gary Cohn former president of Goldman
Sachs a firm that paid five billion
dollars in federal vines because of the
legal behavior Wall Street has
incredible power and I would have hoped
that the president would not have given
a speech like this are you saying if you
were offered $400,000 to give a speech
you would turn it down your clients if
Wall Street offered me that yeah I don't
want Wall Street's money even though
it's trapped on I don't but I must tell
you I really don't have to worry about
that too much I haven't gotten too many
invitations from a lot that help some
people out there be really ever say
never senator yeah